there's so much of this movie that is
practical I love the light bleed onto
the inside of the barrel there yeah
there's a hidden cut in that whip pan oh
I didn't even know hi everyone welcome
back to another episode of visual
effects artists react we have some great
clips for you today
and the janky is CG from the 90s you've
ever seen that big Hollywood actors
around well you know sometimes I just
feel like 90s movies get a bad rap
because you know it's like making fun of
cavemen for not figuring out fire soon
enough no I'm just like Oh Scorpion King
doesn't the 2000s though oh okay it
still sucks today Oh Clint yeah
the ground looks great like the
environments look great it's like the
unsung heroes of these shots everything
that's not the lion especially when you
realize that everything is a hundred
percent generated accepting a purse
opening shot it's on the Sun rising
they're clearly trying to make it look
like it's live-action and no way is
there anything cartoony about this when
you're looking at a live-action lion you
can't have the emotions that you would
get out of a cartoon character and
that's actually a big complaint a lot of
people have all right let me see what
we're dealing with here crazy thing
about environments is they all follow
rules its erosion it's different
materials different rocks being run out
by wind and water and sand and all that
kind of stuff so when the modelers are
making this environment they have to
follow those rules for all this to make
sense and these are things that
subconsciously we can detect very very
quickly like in Avatar
they've always like floating islands
with just waterfalls where's the water
coming from I guess it's coming to
clouds somehow you know I wonder how
much of this stuff was modeled versus
photo scanned because the more you can
ground it in reality with like using
virtual reality to actually hold the
virtual camera or things like that I
think that helps and so I would want to
go all right let's find a rock or some
areas that I could imagine this scene
playing out on and we photoscan that so
keep throwing out the word photo scans
and what we mean by that is there's a
way you can go about modeling really
complex things that exist in real life
and the way it works is basically you
take a bunch of pictures surrounding an
object and then the computer
it basically figures out where these
pictures are overlapping and where they
are of the same detail and from all
these perspectives it can kind of
rebuild the model in 3d in fact this is
how they made a lot of those really good
looking environments and
the star wars battlefront games a lot of
that is just photo scanning and I bet
you a bunch of them are in this movie so
we're looking at the 1998 version of
Godzilla there's been like 30 films
looking at the first American
reimagining of it but CG looks really
good it does look really good this
moment here there's so much of this
movie that is practical whoa it's a
great shot they actually rigged up this
cab 50 feet up into the air and actually
had the dude fall out of it but then
they cut to this reverse shot here do
you think this is a visual effect right
here I think it's actually a miniature
like a puppet waggling the truck around
they did actually have a 1 to 6 scale
giant Godzilla Wow 30 feet tall
it's huge and a little rubber band dude
attached to the cab of the truck they
put it up in the sky and they filmed it
for real we had different practical
Godzilla's in this movie they had all
like the babies they were like real
practical suits they had animatronic
versions of the real Godzilla but on all
the big shots here he's walking around
he's computer-generated and I realized
the thing that makes this work most is
they matched the lighting in the black
levels yeah lawlessly there's different
ways to convey depth but one of the ways
you do it is with atmospheric
perspective you see a lot of paintings
where basically the further something
back is the more haze they add to it the
more they wash out the blacks so you can
see in this shot the two legs of
Godzilla are actually at two different
black levels because they actually have
atmospheric perspective in this shot
because he is so big you're right the
left leg which is close to the camera is
not quite as faded it's actually a
little darker and more contrasting it's
like just a trick that you use to
separate elements in your shot easily
just like how you would do an
out-of-focus background in a InFocus
foreground
this is actually a pretty advanced
compositing shot right now and there's
lots of different elements involved all
of the cars that you see there including
the one underneath
Godzilla's foot are all filmed in Los
Angeles against a green screen and what
they did was they actually dropped a
giant steel sheet I'm honestly kind of
impressed by a lot of the compositing
you see in 90s movies because it's
better than a lot of the stuff you'd see
today using modern technology have you
guys seen or heard of lawn mower I have
no idea what houses is movie stars
pierce brosnan
the movies basically about this crazy VR
scientist this guy is basically his
servant tries it out and becomes a
genius by tapping into virtual worlds
and becomes a super evil chrome boy you
know they got pretty expressive faces
though I was actually gonna say this
there's a lot of emotions going on with
that CG face yeah there's no skin like
stretch it's just individual objects
rotating and clipping with each other so
would you say that they didn't stretch
the pores Niko I would say actually no
looking his face they definitely
stretched the pores look at that yes
this movie came out a year after
Terminator 2 obviously it's not nearly
as good as visual effects but we always
think of like the best movies from the
90s as far as visual effects they're all
made by like ILM they were the name in
visual effects back then yeah all that
software basically be custom-built so it
wasn't like he just started going to the
effects shop people take that for
granted cause these days there are like
dozens of visual effects houses they all
can kind of do basically the same level
of effects okay time out though time out
though if you were alive and watched
this movie around the time it came out
let us know in the comments below what
you thought of it yes I would be really
interested in hearing that like was it
cool or you just like this is dumb
is Lord of war and this is notable
because I had a really fascinating intro
to the entire movie so this is our most
requested clip from the last VFX RS
react thank you for the suggestions if
you guys would like to see us react to a
movie or TV show that you are a big fan
of please let us know we love getting
specific shot recommendations as well
anyways let's check it out there are
over 550 million firearms and worldwide
circulation they're feeling in a very
dangerous than a neighborhood in South
Africa right now like legitimately hmm
look the productions like we shouldn't
film there and the directors like I want
to I think this cage is like yeah this
is my favorite part the camera is like
attached to the blue you think they
actually had a camera in a box for that
for like the guy to open up mm-hmm get
the lighting yeah
oh now we're looking at the mare lightly
over the bullet love the light lead onto
the inside of the barrel there yeah this
terrorists aiming is done and his
friends and the point made
so this opening sequence it's one of the
best movie openers I've ever seen it's
so automatically OnPoint it kind of
ruins the rest of the movie I think as
they actually filmed that after they
filmed the whole movie and they had no
budget so they basically had to make
this for nothing really yep Wow it's one
of those like genius setups where like
the way they previous it and the way
they planned it let them go and execute
this on a low budget okay so I want to
talk about some of the tricks and they
did this in the ways they approached us
with simple techniques and make it super
yeah I want to hear this bring it
alright so this was all shot in 35
millimeter film so there's no digital
cameras here all the cameras are huge
with the actual film reels moving so
when you go into tiny spaces it poses a
problem as I move into the machine here
we move into CG land and we transition
the David Fincher look going through the
coffee cup so now we followed a conveyor
belt and the conveyor belt in the
bullets are all CG and this actually is
an emotion control rig it's just the DP
pushing the camera down to dolly hell
yeah so then the fingers grabbing this
it's an element filmed up close like on
a green screen but what they'd often
have to do for that is it actually
reprojected onto geometries make sure
they pinch the bullet correctly and
cache shadows and all stuff and they
just comped you know the bullets in the
foreground there's a probably hand
animated jiggles on the bullets and
stuff camera in a box straight up it's
just a camera in a box here to get the
light bleeds nice classic comp shot you
know the boat and stuff in the
backgrounds fake the guys in a green
screen etc oh the boat was fake of
course it is I just course don't even
think about it I know you don't even
think about this shot being actually
really solid VFX shot alright so this
sequence coming up here they will had to
get the camera to roll on the ground but
as I mentioned it's a 35-millimeter
camera it can't actually get that low to
the ground they just get the camera as
low as it could they don't roll it they
just slide it though so the rolling is
done in editing
yes they just rotated the video clip but
they took that ground plane reprojected
on just in geometry and then lowered the
virtual camera even lower to the ground
to let them get close to the ground but
they pick up the bullet here posit so
that's the real finger you know filming
close-up real but they needed him to
load it into the magazine so they
reprojected these fingers basically onto
hotdog shaped geometry so they could
warp the fingers to make it do the
action of pushing the bullet into the
gun
honestly in motion it looks pretty nice
it does but you definitely see a live of
weird warping on the tip of the finger
right here at the end it's a great way
to get around a little challenging
moment to stitch all these shots
together that basically takes us to the
end so relatively simple CG good
camerawork good stitching and good
thematic storytelling to make an awesome
intro what an incredible movie this was
it's a good ass movie
well this scene in particular is really
great because it never cuts how is this
camera moving wasn't there just somebody
in that seat and the camera just moved
right through them this whole thing is
filmed on a very custom car rig which is
why they're getting these shots here
this is not green-screen they basically
have a camera that's installed on the
roof of the car that's freely moving on
a mechanical system so the roof is CG
the entire Texas actors they have to
keep popping their chairs down while
that camera that moves over to where
that car so imagine you're doing a scene
where like the love of your life is
dying and you have to go and like
recline just see it really quick and
just be quiet for a moment while the
camera moves in to spot you pop-up scene
up turn it all back on back into the
scene back into acting so hard to do
like that's true professional acting
right there
[Applause]
who's driving the car normally when you
have a car like this and you have to
have a driver the cars on a trailer of
some sort and someone else is driving
the trailer but we look through the
front of the car and through the back
and there's no trailer the car has an
extended like seating area basically
right in front of the front bumper we're
guys just look down really low with a
tiny steering wheel when you're shooting
a giant sequence like this the
probability of you hiding cuts is super
high I watched through this scene and
I've got my estimated hidden cut points
100% there's a hidden cut in that whip
pan she's shot whip pan cut new shot
we're out of the blood yes yeah we just
straight up into a new shot here Clive
Owen and all them have blood on their
clothes that's all been dressed that's
not from just a squib randomly going off
they are all now in new costumes so here
then keep playing this so we're on the
single lane Forest Road right now
correct
so like the glass shatter that is a
really OP clear transition point because
there's no characters and it here's to
see what happens to the road see now
suddenly now there's markings on the
road the other one at the end is
definitely a hidden cut it's just like a
flawless camera transition I don't
remember how this could oh snap
and now our handheld rig is there oh I
didn't even know so fluid yeah it's
gotta be the white um it's going through
the the window there because the camera
rig was inside the car it couldn't go
outside through the window at all
there's tons of hidden cuts in this that
was the hardest thing for me to track
down is any information on to like where
these cuts were so it was really up to
us to kind of pick them apart we are
Wesley Wesley incorporated a lot of
people don't know that Jake's middle
name is Wesley hey guys Wesley and
Wesley here back to tell you about
today's episode sponsor Squarespace now
you might be wondering what's the best
way to get my website out into the world
well tell them Wes
you gotta log onto squarespace.com
we just know that if you don't use
Squarespace you're probably gonna be
found guilty of a crime Squarespace is
beautiful award-winning templates are
100% legal and you'll never get into
trouble using them now in addition to
these beautiful designer templates and
24/7 and Ward winning customer services
they also allow simultaneous posts so if
you post something on Facebook and
Twitter and we guess you'll go via the
other websites as well that's right so
all you got to do is post it once on
your Squarespace and it'll automatically
pull hat to those other platforms this
is amazing but still about traffic
overview I'd love to tell you about
traffic on you think about traffic
overview is you can look at all the data
that's worth it provides you can
overview the traffic that comes to your
site oh yeah and figure out hey this
person came from this place this person
came from that place if you're one of
the many businesses out there in the
world who's got one person doing graphic
design and one person doing a bunch of
other stuff on your web site Squarespace
allows you to have multiple contributors
contribute to your website so if you
guys are interested in maximizing your
potential head on over to
squarespace.com slash chord or a crew
and get 10 percent of your first
purchase
that's right Wesley Wesley incorporated
out thanks for watching everybody please
consider subscribing to the channel if
you have now already we have so many
good videos coming online oh you're also
happening finally Lord of the Rings vs
The Hobbit that's going to be our
Christmas treat for you also we're doing
a Star Wars special the original Star
Wars the ones that define modern visual
effects and we've been doing a lot of
research it's crazy what they did so I
can't wait to tell you all about it so
subscribe so you don't miss it